[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
Daniela Blandón nuevamente con nosotros
en esta mesa de trabajo de directo
América y vamos a hablar de elon Dani
porque ya hizo sus primeros cambios en
Twitter pues mire El Magnate de los
autos de lujo Raúl ya sabemos reveló que
se desempeñará como presidente de esta
compañía que es una red social que
compró por 44.000 millones de dólares en
una presentación a la comisión de
valores de Estados Unidos
mosca también reveló que se convirtió en
el único miembro de la junta directiva
después de haberlos despedido a todos
aunque después dijo que esto era
temporal
mosca también dio luces sobre lo que
podrían ser sus próximos pasos lo invito
a que veamos este gráfico Stephen King
que es el escritor de obras célebres
como it o el resplandor tuiteó a sus
siete millones de Seguidores que no
estaría dispuesto a pagar 20 dólares al
mes para mantener su cuenta verificada
en Twitter y que antes deberían pagarle
a él
113 millones de Seguidores de Moss
pudieron ver esta respuesta tenemos que
pagar las cuentas de alguna manera
Twitter no puede depender completamente
de los anunciantes qué tal 8 dólares qué
tal 8 dólares Bueno no es tanto pero
pues igual para eso y también otra
polémica como el regreso de trompa de la
red social también tuiteó dijo que sí
pues le pagarían por cada pregunta Mejor
dicho ya Twitter sería una más
millonario todavía Bueno vamos a hablar
de las grandes petroleras Dani del mundo
porque terminaron de presentar sus
resultados financieros Cómo le fue pues
ya habíamos visto cómo son móvil Chevron
y shell reportaron a sus accionistas que
en el tercer trimestre de este año
ganaron en conjunto más de 40 mil
millones de dólares el turno de este
martes es para otras gigantes la
británica Pipi y aramco de Arabia
Saudita la primera duplicó con creces
sus ganancias del tercer trimestre con
respecto al año anterior hasta más de 8
mil millones de dólares impulsada por
los altos precios del petróleo desde
luego
por su parte el gigante árabe aramuco
informó que su beneficio trimestral
subió 39% interanual hasta 42 mil
millones de dólares casi lo mismo que
todas juntas en ambos casos el segundo
el mejor resultado de la historia es
este después de los tres meses
anteriores el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden después de criticarlas
hizo una advertencia al menos para las
estadounidenses
en tiempos de guerra cualquier empresa
que reciba una ganancia inesperada
histórica como esta tiene la
responsabilidad de actuar Más allá del
estrecho interés propio de sus
accionistas ejecutivos creo que tienen
la responsabilidad de actuar en interés
de los consumidores su comunidad y su
país invertir en Estados Unidos
aumentando la producción y la capacidad
de refinación no quieren hacer eso
tienen la oportunidad de hacerlo bajar
los precios para los consumidores en la
estación de gasolina ya sabes si no lo
hacen van a pagar un impuesto más alto
sobre sus antecedentes de ganancias y
enfrentarán otras restricciones mi
equipo trabajará con el congreso para
analizar estas opciones es hora de que
estas empresas dejen de especular con la
guerra esta situación positiva para las
empresas no es la misma Dani que de las
grandes automotrices sí Raúl las grandes
ensambladoras de vehículos del mundo
están luchando contra el aumento de Los
costos de los materiales y también la
persistentes escasez de semiconductores
todos han venido mostrando beneficios
dispares que van desde Toyota que es el
mayor fabricante del mundo por volumen
de ventas esta empresa registró un
descenso del 31% en sus ganancias
trimestrales hasta septiembre Pero
también esta Ford que tuvo pérdidas de
más de 800 millones de dólares
impulsadas por su decisión de invertir
menos en el negocio de conducción
Autónoma que le ha traído pérdidas
contrario a General Motors que anunció
que duplicará las inversiones de su
unidad de robo taxi y que también acaba
de anunciar un alza del 37% en sus
ganancias trimestrales vamos ahora
indicadores económicos las acciones de
Estados Unidos abrieron al alza
comenzando un noviembre muy optimista
con la mirada puesta también sobre la
decisión de dos días la reunión de dos
días de la reserva Federal que empieza
hoy los inversionistas tienen la
esperanza de que la fe pueda comenzar a
ser menos agresiva con el aumento de
tazas en Europa el mercado que opera hoy
al alza también está muy atento a lo que
diga la Fed Y es que ya se da por
descontado que va a haber un nuevo
aumento en la tasa de intervención pero
se están esperando señales sobre lo que
podría suceder en diciembre y en Asia el
principal índice de Hong Kong el
hanksense se trepó más de un 5%, después
de una encuesta de la industria
manufacturera china que mostró que la
actividad ha mejorado y esto ayuda a
contrarrestar todos estos temores que
hay sobre el covid 19 como siempre Dani
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica de esta mañana de
martes mañana más economía mañana con la
decisión de la Fed con la decisión de la
Fed que por supuesto va a incidir en
todos los mercados del mundo como
siempre lo hemos hablado Dani como
siempre Muchísimas gracias nosotros
volamos sin escalas directo hasta